SHAUNA: I am very
happy to introduce
Malachi Rempen, the
creator of the web
comic "Itchy Feet."
itchyfeetcomic.com.
Malachi is from
the US originally
but now he lives in Berlin.
And his wife is Italian
and also lives in Berlin.
So they have a lot of experience
with being expats and language
learning.
So the comic is about
travel and language learning
and occasionally
life as an expat.
So it seems logical
that this should
be interesting to this audience
because many, many people here
are experts and
most have learned
one foreign language at least,
most of the time at least two.
So maybe for some background,
I'm a fan of this comic.
And I thought it made sense
that other Googlers should be.
And it turns out they are
because a fellow Googler sees
one of the comics that is posted
about Zurich and he writes,
oh hey, if you're
ever in Zurich,
you should look me up and
come down to the office
and I can give you
a tour of Google.
And then I jumped on
the comment thread
and I said, oh, yeah,
yeah, how about you come
and give a talk at Google?
And to both of our
surprise and delight,
Malachi replies to the thread.
He says, yeah, OK.
So here he is and I will let
him do the rest of the speaking.
MALACHI REMPEN: Thanks, Shauna.
Everyone hear me all right?
Right on.
Got my notes.
Cool.
So, yeah, as Shauna said,
I'm Malachi Ray Rempen.
I do "Itchy Feet," the
travel and language comic.
How many of you here
have seen or heard of it?
Are you kidding me?
All right.
Good point.
Well, that's all right.
I want the hand count
to be high in my head
so I can be like, yeah, cool.
So I was actually born in
Geneva, not far from here.
But I only lived there for
like a year or so and then
my family, we moved
to New Mexico,
where I grew up in Albuquerque.
And then I went to
film school in L.A.
That's what I do professionally,
I'm a freelance filmmaker.
And comics were always
ever just a hobby for me.
It was never something that
I wanted to do professionally
or anything like that.
But I'm not here talking
at Google for my movies.
But what I did want
to talk about--
and I'm going to go
through some of the comics
that I've done some of
the stories behind them
and some of the
problems that I've
had with certain ones and sort
of things that I've learned
and most of all, what
I ended up learning
more about storytelling and
more about creative endeavors
and what it means to
be creative and art
through this comic than I ever
did through any of the films
or through film school
or any of that stuff.
So I want to share some of
that stuff with you guys.
So after L.A., I
moved to France.
I lived-- we lived in
Lyons and I went there
for a girl-- somebody
who may or may not
be at the back of the room.
And my then girlfriend, now
wife, Iris, she was studying,
doing her Erasmus program there.
And I thought, well,
I'll come along.
France.
Why not?
L.A. sucks.
And I wanted to--
it was my first time
living outside the
country I wanted
to have some way of chronicling
what was happening to me
and the things
that were going on.
But something to send
my mom every week
that I could sort of explain
like what life is like.
But I didn't want
to just do a blog
or like to send a
really long email.
And I had always doodled as
a kid on papers and stuff,
so I thought, well,
I'll just do a comic.
And oh, yeah, here's me
being interested in movies.
A side note that will
be important later,
I was always into sort of
the big fantasy movies.
Like I was always into the "Star
Wars" and into "The Matrix"
when I was a kid.
And then as I got older, like
the Coen brothers, the Wes
Anderson, like the
people who were
building worlds who
were making these sort
of fantastical things.
I was never really into realism.
That aside, back
to the main story.
I started "Le Spleen en France,"
which was the original title.
And originally, the
guy was a spleen.
And all the characters
were little body organs.
There was like a
heart, and an eyeball,
and a pancreas, these things.
But it just got irritating
to draw a pancreas.
And anyway, a spleen doesn't
look anything like that.
So I just ended up
being a [INAUDIBLE].
But you'll see in some of
the early comics, that's
where that comes from.
And originally, the comics were
just about my very personal
experiences.
Like I said, like you would
write to a friend or family
member.
Like this is what
happened to me this week.
So this was the
first comic I did.
Can you read the-- how's that?
Is that all right?
Yeah, that's all right.
So this was the first.
It was just about like, you
bone up on your foreign language
and then you try it out and
then you just sort of freeze up.
I'm sure a lot of you-- how
many of you here are Swiss?
So you haven't had that problem
here in Switzerland at least.
But all the original--
here's another one
which is kind of
about when you're
for a foreigner
in a new country,
you sort of find yourself-- you
represent for everybody there,
like you represent
everybody from your country.
And you have to
answer for things
that your country has done
or cultural things that
might-- from
wherever you're from,
like you suddenly become
the representative
of where you're from.
And at the time when I
was in Lyons in 2011,
I guess it never
really goes away,
but America's always in the
news in sort of a bad way,
especially then.
And I always found
it a lot easier
to defuse the
conversation and move on
to something that I
didn't have to answer
for when we talked about food.
Because there's nothing
that French people
love more than
talking about food--
or Italians for that matter.
And I spent a lot
of time with both.
And then this is
the last one I did,
which is just sort of
about when you come back
from a really long experience
and somebody from home
asks, "how was it?"
and you go like,
"great," because there's
no real-- you can't explain
all of what it was like.
You can't sort of
get across-- anyway,
they're not really interested.
They just want to
now that it was good.
And that was supposed to be it.
I was only supposed to be
in Lyons for four months,
or we were, and I was supposed
to go back to the States.
That was in 2011.
It's now 2015.
I haven't left Europe yet.
And I ended up-- again, my then
girlfriend who was studying,
she got an opportunity to do
her field work in Morocco.
So I said like, yeah,
Morocco, I'm coming too.
I'm not going back to L.A. after
I had this great experience.
We ended up living
a year in Lyons
and then in the spring of
2012, she went to Morocco.
We went to Morocco
and I thought well,
I can bring back this comic.
I can make it a sort
of travel and exploring
the world kind of comic and not
just about my personal self.
It could be-- I
have lots of plans
to travel around the world.
We can make it something bigger.
So it couldn't be the
"Le Spleen en France,"
let's make it something a little
bit more general about travel.
And that became "Itchy Feet."
Again, though, at
the beginning it
was just sort of a chronicle
of specific experiences.
So this was one of
the early ones I did.
And if you've never had
to take a taxi from El
Hoceima to Rouadi in
Morocco, you probably
can't relate too well
to what's going on here.
It's kind of interesting
and kind of funny,
but there's no real
personal connection to that.
This one comes
from-- I did notice
that when it was really
difficult to speak
French with French people, at
least when you're starting out
because the accent's so strong,
but also because somebody
speaks a language
as a native speaker,
you speak it in a slang way.
You use lots of weird
figures of speech and sort
of a street version
of the language.
And when you're
learning it, you're
learning a very academic,
proper sort of classroom version
of that language.
And they don't really mix.
And anyway, you feel
like you're just
leagues behind a native
speaker, which you are.
Whereas in Morocco, because for
them, they speak fluent French,
but they don't speak
it as a mother tongue.
So they speak it a
fluent classroom French.
So it's kind of a nice
place to meet halfway.
And this was me
trying to express
that it's a lot easier to speak
a language with somebody who's
also learning that language
than it is to someone
who's a native speaker.
I don't know if you
necessarily improve.
But these are the
first comics where
I was trying to express
something beyond just making
a funny joke about something.
But it doesn't always work out.
So at the beginning of any
cultural or artistic endeavor,
you're always trying to--
you're feeling out the audience.
You're feeling out what
works, what doesn't work,
what kind of the
sense of humor is.
And my sense of humor is not
necessarily "Itchy Feet,"
believe it or not.
"Itchy Feet" doesn't
make me laugh that often.
But my sense of humor
is a lot more absurdest
and sort of wilder.
Like this one in particular.
I went to Turkey, in the
region called Cappadocia,
and they have these
beautiful, they're
called fairy towers
or fairy castle
abodes which are like these
ancient, naturally formed stone
spires that then
were carved into
and people made their houses.
And it dates back to the
Middle Ages and such.
And I thought it
was kind of funny.
They looked kind of
like termite nests.
And so I just thought,
wow, wouldn't be funny
if there were actually
giant termites in there that
were enslaved to people.
And so I made this comic
which is exactly that.
And I still think
it's hilarious.
But it really--
nobody else-- like,
it didn't really
go over that well.
Not the least with
Turkish people who
didn't find it funny at all.
But I learned a lot from this.
I learned a lot
about finding sort
of what resonates with people.
And you learn more
from the ones that
fall flat than you do,
I think, from the ones
necessarily that
hit on the mark.
Here's another example of one
where the first time people
actually got angry at me.
I had noticed that in
Turkey-- in Germany,
the Turkish people often
complain, I think justifiably,
that they are treated like
second class citizens in a way
by the Germans.
And I had noticed it
in Turkey, that they
sort of just in passing,
that they kind of
did the same with Kurds.
And so I made this
comic about it.
But people got upset at me.
And this was the first time
I actually got hate mail.
And I kind of realized that I
don't know enough about this.
I'm not in a place to speak for
either of these two parties.
I was a tourist for like
two weeks and I walk through
and I think I can
have something to say
about this ongoing and very
deeply rooted conflict.
So this is the one where I
was like, I should stay away
from politics.
I should just stick to
stuff that you know.
Stick to what you know.
And so that's what I did.
And when I moved to
Germany, I made a lot
about German
culture, which I felt
a lot more comfortable making
fun of, being half German
myself.
And like this one
in particular, which
I'm sure will resonate in
Switzerland just as well, which
is coming from France,
in Lyons, the red light
is just a suggestion.
The red light is just-- it's
only so that you know to look
for cars when you're crossing.
Like it's not a-- but whereas,
when I came to Germany,
it was like, the
red light is law.
The red light is to protect you.
You are beholden to the light.
And this one was great because
I think Germans recognize
this about themselves.
And they can recognize
this sort of funny quality
about the more ridiculous
in their number.
And I think that's
another important thing.
Oh, I have another
one that's sort
of along these lines, which
is actually in Switzerland.
Which is that I came
last summer and noticed
that the Swiss would
prefer not to speak
high German if possible.
Like they'd rather speak
English than speak it,
despite the fact they're very
proud, and justifiably again,
very proud of the fact that they
can speak perfect high German,
it's just sort of
bad on the tongue.
Just like eww.
And so they prefer
to speak English.
And I think what I
learned about doing
these two comics
in particular is
if I'm going to make fun of
something aspect of a culture,
then it's better to sort of
take it and exaggerate it
rather than just sort
of commenting blankly
on what it is.
Take it, make it ridiculous,
and then you can kind of
see the truth behind it.
All right.
Then I got, after
this one and others,
I got more into also doing more
comics about language learning.
And this was the first
one that I really got
a really positive feedback on.
And it's just about the fact
that again, Germans' English
is so much better
than your German
that it's just so much
easier just to speak English.
Especially in Berlin.
It may not be the case inside
the countryside in Germany,
but in Berlin where
I'm living right now,
you'd be hard pressed to
find a German who didn't also
speak perfect English,
especially in my generation.
And this was the
first time that I
was sort of trying to make
comics that were communicating
an idea and they weren't
just making a weird joke.
I was trying to--
you're feeling out
the point at which you
and your audience meet
and where you can communicate
to them through a message.
And these are the first ones
where I was trying to do that
and I was succeeding, where
I'd failed in the ones
that you've seen before.
And this is the first time,
the first time that people
said to me, people were
commenting and saying,
this is so true.
That's so true.
And that was something
I'd heard a lot when I
was going through film school.
Like I said, I was really into
building worlds and making
these sort of fantastical
things and spaceships and aliens
and back in time
and stuff like that.
But what people kept saying
to me, what I kept hearing
over and over is two things.
One is write what you know.
You hear that a lot.
And then the second
is tell the truth.
And I didn't really know what
either of those things meant.
How do you tell the truth if
you're making a space fantasy?
How do you write what
you know if you're
writing about dinosaurs
on Mars or whatever it is?
And this was the first--
through "Itchy Feet"
was the first time
that I started
to understand what
tell the truth meant,
which is speak from
your experience.
Speak from your perspective
on the world and things
that you personally
have gone through.
Because if you
have, then there's
chances are that
other people have too.
And that's where
you connect people.
And that's how large
space fantasies
are so relatable to us.
It's not the space fantasy part.
It's the human story
at the center of it
that we connect to
as human beings.
So thank you, "Itchy Feet."
This one, again,
this was just sort
of a general about
how I had noticed
that the more you
learn of a language,
the more you realize
you have left to learn.
It just gets harder and harder
as the higher you climb up
this hill.
And you realize that
your goal is actually
getting farther and
farther away, depending
on what your goal is.
And the around
this time I started
to see that the
comics had become
fairly popular within the
language learning community.
And this was sort of,
this became-- still
is today-- my bread
and butter of the comic
is the people who were
learning new languages.
Because there wasn't
really a voice
for people who were going
through that experience,
at least not in comic form.
And so this is when I
started to realize I
was not just doing
comics myself.
That I was serving a
community of people.
That is was something
I was doing for others.
And this is another
really important lesson.
And when it comes to
creative endeavors,
there is a certain
element of it that
has to come from you, right?
You have to be honest.
You have to be truthful.
You have to write
from what you know.
But it's not for you.
The end product of truly
resonating art or truly good
creative work-- not saying
that this necessarily
is art-- just saying
that the goal of art
is to reach other people.
It's for other people.
You're doing it to
teach other people
or to reach out to other people.
It's about-- you're
serving not receiving,
if that makes any sense.
And one where this didn't go so
well, oh, yeah, well, this one.
This is one that was, I think,
was one of my biggest failures.
Again, it's a Swiss comic.
And the idea came from
travelling through Switzerland
and seeing that they
just so many lawn gnomes,
like in their-- especially
in the countryside.
They're just everywhere.
Just sometimes overflowing.
Like, I don't think this
drawing is necessarily
an exaggeration on the first.
And so the joke
was kind of like,
oh, well, it's kind of
like a drug addiction.
Like, I think
you've had too much.
Like an intervention.
But because-- it's the first
time people going, like,
I love the comic, but
I don't get this one.
And it was the first time that
usually, I send the comics,
they go through my wife first.
And she laughs at them.
And if she laughs,
that means it goes out.
And if she says, I don't
get it, that means nobody's
going to get it.
And this was the first
time she said, I don't get.
And I was like, I don't think
you're right about that.
Like, maybe just-- maybe
it's a language issue thing
or maybe she doesn't know about
drug interventions or whatever.
Whatever it is, I'm
wrong and she's right.
And I was completely
wrong and nobody got it.
And so I think the important,
lesson I learned from this one,
certainly is always
listen to my wife.
But as far as
creative work goes,
to get outside perspective.
So sometimes you can
be very tunnel visioned
and think that your perspective
is the only one that matters.
And in reality,
like I said, you're
doing this for other
people, so it's
good to have a second
voice to be like,
this doesn't reach me,
especially an honest one.
Or this one does.
Like and if she laughs
out loud and says,
this is going to be a good
one, then it usually is.
As far as perspectives go,
it can be hard sometimes--
can be tricky, I
wouldn't say hard--
but it's tricky to
represent features
of other cultures
because of this fact
that we all each come from
a particular perspective
and we all come from our
own cultural perspective.
So this one was a perfectly
respectably popular strip
as far as my standards go, that
is about how, again, Germans
speak such good English.
You have to go all the
way out to the countryside
to find someone who you
could practice German with.
And even then,
they speak English.
And what I had
done with this one,
is you see in the
sixth panel here,
in this one here, I wanted
the name of the sign
to be something that was
the equivalent in English,
of Nowhereville or like
Podunktown or whatever.
Just this imaginary place where
it's in the middle of nowhere.
So I asked a friend in Berlin
of mine and he said, oh, yeah,
we call that, we
say, "Buxtehude."
So I said, fine, Buxtehude.
Perfect.
I've done my research.
Put it up there and all
these people from Buxtehude
started writing comments
going, like, it's not
in-- you've clearly never been
to Buxtehude because it's not
in the Alps.
We're not in--
we're near Munich.
It's on the sea and
we're very respectable
and it's a nice big city.
And I was like, I'm so sorry.
I had no-- I didn't
mean any offense.
What would you say for
the middle of nowhere?
And they said,
"Hintertuptingen,"
which is sort of
yeah, it just means--
it's sort of a word that
just means back of the woods,
nowhere kind of a thing.
But that was-- that was--
the lesson from this one
was definitely like,
if you don't personally
know for a fact that this is
the way that it is universally,
especially when it comes
to cultural matters,
do your research.
Check it twice.
And now I go through
every-- sometimes
I have comics,
especially more recently
that feature a lot of
languages that I don't speak
or even read.
And so I always, like,
minimum two or three people
I try and put it past them so
that they can sort of check
off and go like, yes,
this makes sense or no,
you didn't use a dirty
word here or whatever.
Because I don't know.
How was I supposed
to know Buxtehude?
Never heard of that before.
And again, this
is an earlier one.
And it comes from again,
about personal experience.
This didn't come from me.
This came from my mom who
went to India and said,
like, oh, we had
these great lassis
and did you know they use these
old washing machines to make
the lassis with.
And I thought it would
be hilarious if like, oh,
wouldn't it be great if
they left their laundry
in the lassi washing machine.
Well, again, nobody--
like, people from India
were commenting,
I've never heard
of this in my entire life.
I'm from India.
And it was just that
first of all, again,
it's not really
a cultural thing.
It's just making a dumb joke.
And then also it's
not my perspective.
So I stopped doing
secondhand stories.
I stopped doing stories
that came from other people
because I don't know what
their experience was.
Maybe that was just
in this one village
they make them out of
the old washing machines.
Maybe it's just this one
weird old lady who did it.
And unless you had been
also to these lady's house
and had her lassis,
you would have
no way of knowing that they were
made out of washing machines.
So it's always best to
rely on-- to make sure
that you're grounding in
your own personal experience.
And this is where
it definitely works.
Like this one I think that I
sort of fired on all cylinders
with, which is just about
how in Catalonia, they
don't have Santa Claus.
They have this flying
log that the kids have
to hit with sticks and then
it craps out their presents.
And this was the first time
I didn't use a punchline
because it was like, I
couldn't think of anything that
was possibly more ridiculous
than this idea, that it
was just like, just let
it exist on its own.
And again with this
one I was like,
this I have to do
my research on.
Maybe it's just one family,
like one bizarre region
that they do this.
No.
I've checked with Catalonians
and they're all like,
we love this crazy
traditional that we do.
And they have more
Christmas traditions
that have to do with crapping.
Like that's some sort of
thing that they do there.
But again, checked my sources.
Checked multiple people.
Went out on Twitter going
like, everyone from Catalonia,
is this true?
And they were all
like, absolutely.
So done.
Great.
And we can laugh.
We can all laugh about it.
So what I didn't want to
just do-- language learning,
it's great, again, that
that's the biggest community.
But I wanted to also
expand and make more
about the travel experience
and just general travel,
foreign cultures, going around
the world and sort of seeing
the world from foreign eyes.
And so like, for
example, this one
is about how the
more you travel,
the less you have to pack.
And again, taking
it, exaggerating it,
but making it less specific
to my personal experience
and trying to make
it more generally
relatable to general audiences.
I guess it's part of feeling out
what the audience is interested
in, what they're reacting to,
how you're resonating or not
with different people.
This one was because when I
was a teenager backpacking
through Europe, for
example, I always
had the big dirty backpack.
I was one of those
guys that had all kinds
of different
compartments and stuff
and then tons of
everything I could possibly
need, this huge heavy thing.
And very proud of it and always
kind of sneering at the jet
setters with their
fancy bags and stuff.
And then last year I
went on a business trip,
like a proper business trip
where I had to have a suit
and I had to have
like a rolly bag.
And I was like, oh
my god, I don't have
to carry everything on my back.
It has wheels and I
can pull it around.
And it's like, I
couldn't believe it.
So again, just comes from
those sorts of observations.
This one, for example, has to do
with going to--I went to India
when I was in high school and I
noticed that it wasn't until I
came back that the
real culture shock hit.
Because you expect
it to be weird,
and you expect it
to be different,
and you expect there to be
all kinds of different--
you expect it to
be uncomfortable
when you're going to
someplace that's so
different from your own personal
culture, wherever that is.
And it's not till you come
back to your own country
that you sort of realize
like, whoa, this is suddenly
very different.
Because that's not
what you're expecting.
Like, for example, in the
States, I always come back,
every time I come back to the
States, it's just amazing to me
how big everything is
and how it's just--
I still can't comprehend.
I mean, this isn't even
really an exaggeration.
People are huge.
Portions are huge.
Supermarkets are just-- a big
supermarket here in Europe
could fit in one of the
aisles of these places.
Right.
So I think what I learned from
strips like this in particular
is that internal
observations are oftentimes
more interesting and
definitely more relatable
than external observations.
Like it's great that we can
laugh about the Christmas
crapping log, but I think the
ones that we can all connect on
are things where you
look back on your own--
you dig into your own
personal internal experience.
And so for any
creative endeavor,
that's what you have to do.
I think it was Hemingway who
said that when he writes,
he just sits down
at his typewriter
and then bleeds because
he's just digging up
all of this emotional
detritus that comes out of him
and just like, I'm
bleeding it on the page.
This isn't the
work of Hemingway,
but the idea is that
internal-- looking back inside
is more interesting
than you observing
upon the outside world.
So what makes a good
comic, I've also learned,
is that ironically, people
all the time come up to you
say, oh, here's something
funny that happened to me.
This would make a great comic.
And I actually found that
people's personal travel
experiences, including my
own, as I said earlier,
they're not that successfully
translatable to a general comic
because they're so
specific that it could only
have happened to that
one particular person
on that particular day
on that particular trip.
If you were to go on the
same trip as somebody else,
and walked the exact same
path that they walked,
you would come back with
totally different stories.
That's why travel
stories are fun to hear
because they're so particular
to that person's experience.
For that reason, I
stay away from making
comics that are about personal,
specific travel stories.
Man, if I could figure
out a way to do it,
like if I could figure
out a way to make comics
about these kinds of
stories without making fun
of the person
telling the story, I
think I would have a much
longer list of to do comics.
So just go briefly a little
bit to how I make the comics.
My sketchbook.
And I have pen,
paper, and eraser.
I first, when I come
up with an idea,
I don't start with
the joke because that
turns into comics that tend
to be much more shallow.
I start with the idea.
So I start with the
observation or like the thing
that I've noticed.
The truth.
I start with the true statement.
Which I think is a
good starting point
in any kind of
creative endeavor.
So for instance,
this week I want
to do one about Switzerland
because we're here
in Switzerland.
And there's been one
of the top my list--
I've got this list on my
phone of all the "Itchy Feet"
ideas that I've been
wanting to do a comic about,
but I can't think
of how to do it.
Sometimes they'll sit
there and they'll germinate
on this list for a year.
In this case, it was a year.
I wanted to do one about how
the Swiss trains are always
on time, but like to
a ridiculous degree.
They're super on time.
And they leave right on time.
Exactly when they're
supposed to leave.
Which again, is sort
of banal observation,
but it would make a
good comic if I could
take that and exaggerate it.
So I start with that idea and I
think of what the joke's going
to be and then I sketch it out.
This on the left
side of the page,
is sort of the rough sketch.
So here's the sketch I
came up with the comic.
You don't have to
worry about-- it's kind
of-- with the arrows
and stuff figuring out.
But the point is to get it
all down there on the actual,
on this sketch version before I
go to the actual drawing of it.
And the reason is
that you always
want to begin a project
with the end in mind.
And this is something
that I've definitely
learned through "Itchy Feet."
It's taught me a lot
about the filmmaking
that I do, and the
screenwriting, for example
that I do.
When you want to start
a creative project
and you have a
creative idea, you
want to get right
to the fun part.
You want to get
right to the part
where like, for filmmaking
for me, is like being on set
and working with the actors
and placing the camera
and working with the
special effects people
and figuring out the
costumes and stuff.
That's the fun part.
But you can't get to that part
until you have the script.
And not just have it,
but that it's done
and that it's a complete story.
You can't just be-- I mean
some directors totally
do improvise on set-- but I'm
not that kind of creative.
I need to have it all worked
out beforehand so that you
don't get messy when you're
in the actual part that's fun.
Then you have this
backbone that you
can rely on to be good at
the end of the process.
And so that needs to be there.
And this sketch, this
like, rough sketch
has to be there before
I start drawing.
The fun part is the
drawing but it has to wait.
Then I do the pencil
sketch and I ink it.
And I ink all the pieces
separately on the page
and then I scan that.
I take a photo of it and put
it into Photoshop and kind
of align all the materials.
I try to, as much as
possible, stay away
from the computer because all
of our lives are on the computer
these days.
Our work is on the computer.
Our movies are on the computer.
The things that we do for
fun are on the computer.
Our games, chatting with
friends, Skyping, all of it
is on the computer.
And so I wanted to keep
as much of this process
where I could just
take like half an hour
and put the computer aside and
do something with my hands,
something physical.
Again, I do it in
Photoshop and the end,
because it's better and easier.
But I don't want
to use the tablets.
I refuse to use those
drawing tablets for now.
And then this,
the final version.
Right.
So this will come out on
Sunday, which again, ha, ha,
they're still on time,
these Swiss trains
that even a delay is
only seven seconds.
So the style of "Itchy Feet"
comes mostly from, as I said,
I wasn't really ever
a comics person.
I did read the newspaper
comics, so a lot of it's
influenced by comics like
"Calvin Hobbes," "The Far
Side," and the other ones.
I would read them
every single morning.
And the funny thing is.
In the States anyway, they have
what's called The Funny Pages.
And the Funny Pages
is just a page
in the newspaper that's top
to bottom newspaper comics.
And none of them are
funny, for the most part,
but they're called
The Funny Pages.
And I remember my
brothers asking me,
because I would read
them religiously
every single morning,
why do you read this?
You're not laughing.
You're not even smiling.
And I think it was because
I liked the drawings.
I learned a lot about the
cartoony style of the drawings
of the newspapers.
And it was only recently that I
looked at the "Itchy Feet" guy
and I kind of saw
where the two of them
met, where it came from.
So it's sort of this, if
you take Homer Simpson,
and if you've seen
Don Hertzfeldt, whose
fantastic rejected
cartoons, these sort
of bizarre, abstract,
hilarious cartoons.
You smash them together and
get the "Itchy Feet" guy.
So the lesson from that
is stealing is good.
In a creative sense.
Steve Jobs that said that--
have you every seen these videos
"Everything is a Remix?"
It's this guy that basically
thinks-- these video essays
about exactly this fact.
That everything
creative in our culture
is remixed from something else.
There's no such thing
as an original anything.
And in that video,
he has this example
of this interview with Steve
Jobs, this video interview
where he says, we
steal shamelessly
from other great ideas.
We steal great
ideas all the time
because they're great ideas and
they belong to us, to everyone.
And then directly after that, it
was like when Android came out
and he was saying
something about,
I will go thermonuclear
war on this.
They've stolen our ideas.
They've taken our best objects.
People get protective.
But creatively, I do agree that
it's not just it's OK to steal
and that there is
no original ideas,
it's that you had no choice.
You don't create in a vacuum.
You create from
your inspirations
and you create from the things
that subconsciously burrow
into your brain like
little parasites
and then come out into
bean-shaped stick figure
characters with bulging eyes.
So that's "Itchy Feet" now.
What "Itchy Feet"
could be for me--
I mean, again, as long as
I keep telling the truth,
I feel like I'll have
something that everyone will be
able to relate to in some way.
Now that I've married
this famous Italian girl,
we've started sort of
an international family.
And so it will be,
eventually-- I'm
working more strips
into how it's
like to be married to somebody
that's from a different culture
and be part of family
that's a completely
foreign culture to yours.
And I assume at some
point down the line
there will be lots of
little "Itchy Feet" people
and it'll be about--
the comic might change
to being what it's like
to travel with a family.
And man, who can't relate to
screaming kids on the plane?
Or the problems with the
way different cultures
treat kids as they
travel around.
And then I assume,
at some point,
it will be about
traveling as an old person
when robots carry our luggage.
And I suppose
they'll probably put
"Itchy Feet" on my tombstone,
despite the fact that again,
this is a hobby.
This isn't what I
do professionally.
It's just something
I do for fun.
But when you do something
and it resonates
with even one or two other
people, you got to keep going.
You're serving someone.
Suddenly you're serving them.
You're doing it
for someone else.
And so I guess that would be if
I had any one particular take
away that it would be that find
something that's creative--
and I don't have to tell you
guys this, you work at Google--
but to do outside
of your work life
and tell the truth with it.
Whatever it is, tell the truth.
And if you don't know what
that means, that's OK.
I didn't either and I'm
not sure I still do.
But keep doing it
until you find out
what that is, what it means
to tell the truth in anything
that's creative work.
As for myself, I
have another project
that I just started which
is a series of kids' fantasy
adventure books.
And it's where
I've managed to mix
my love of like I was talking
about, fantastic adventure
with the truth of what it's
like to have that joy of getting
on a boat or a plane and
traveling to some new place
and having some new adventure.
And so that's the
feeling that I want
to instill into 12-year-olds
or at least bring up
from my internal 12-year-old.
That's it.
So yeah, I'm on Patreon,
if you want to support
the hilarious comic arts.
And I believe that's
all I have to say.
Thank you so much.
If you have any questions,
we'll do a little Q and A. Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there a
[INAUDIBLE] how often does it
happen like you finish
one cartoon and then you
have to say, OK, I totally
have to reject this?
Or something.
So every cartoon you publish,
there are like three others
that you reject?
MALACHI REMPEN: Oh, I see.
Like, as far as ones
that get past my wife?
It depends-- sorry?
The question was
what do I-- how often
do I reject strips, right.
What's the success to failure
rate of the-- most of them
go through.
I would say 90%
of them go through
because I try and figure it out.
First of all, I've
gotten better recently
at figuring out
what's going to work
and what's not going to work.
At the beginning
though, early on, I
did a lot of going back and
like, drawing a new frame
and going back and adding it
and maybe changing the joke
and trying to figure out a
way because she might say,
like I get what you're trying
to say, but it's not funny.
Or whatever.
And then I would try
and refigure the joke.
But I'd say it doesn't happen
very often because I've
gotten more disciplined
about finishing it
at the sketch level, where
the core of it's done.
And then the rest is just
basically frosting on the cake.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, one more.
So how many do you make?
So what's your typical,
like one per month?
MALACHI REMPEN: Oh, I do
them weekly, every week.
Every Sunday.
And recently, it's been a lot
of very, very last minute,
like a Saturday night.
But I've done it for three
years now, every single week.
Even when I go on a trip,
I'll write them in advance.
Like right now, I've got
some travels coming up
so I've written like the
next four or five in advance
and I've scheduled them to go.
But that rarely happens.
Usually, it's like me
scrambling at the last minute
to think of something funny.
Yes, Jeff.
AUDIENCE: Obviously the ideas
sit in your head for a while.
You said you've had
some for a year.
How long does it
take you [INAUDIBLE]?
MALACHI REMPEN: How
long does it take me
once I have the idea to
actually sit down and draw it?
Oh, man, that depends on how
close I am to the deadline.
Sometimes I'll sit-- I've
found, and it's not just
with "Itchy Feet," it's
with writing as well,
that a big part of
the creative process
is staring blankly into
space or staring at a wall
and accomplishing nothing.
Or you think you're not
accomplishing anything.
In reality, what you're doing
is you're working on it,
you're stewing it,
you're cooking it.
But it feels like a
lot of wasted time
that you're sitting
starting at a wall.
And I used to hate that part
of it until I read about Pixar.
That they actually,
they know that this
is how the creative
process works
and they schedule that
time into their development
of their stories so that
when they hit the wall,
even if it's a big group
of genius storytellers,
they hit the wall, they can't
figure out what to do next,
and they go like,
all right, well,
let's go do something
else for a couple days.
And it's planned.
They plan this block.
This section where
you're just sitting
there banging your head
against an idea and you
can't think of something.
So to answer your question,
usually like a couple hours.
Usually, I sit there and
I'll have blocked this time
aside to do it.
So I'll sit there and
go, OK, this is the idea.
That doesn't work.
Oh, this would work.
Nah, that doesn't work.
And then a couple
hours later, like
once it clicks, and I, like I
said, I get the sketch down,
then it's just an hour or so of
like, drawing it, scanning it,
getting it up there.
You can see, these aren't the
most complicated drawings.
I deliberately
wanted to simplify
it to make it something
that I could reasonably
do in my free time.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What is your
day job like? [INAUDIBLE].
MALACHI REMPEN: Yeah.
My day job is a, like I
said, freelance filmmaker.
So I do commercials.
I do Internet films.
I do image films.
I do promotional films.
I do short documentaries.
I do sort of whatever
comes down the pipeline.
But because I do that,
I'm self-employed
and it's freelance, that's
not really a day job.
Hey, it would be great like
if I could figure out a way
to make "Itchy
Feet" pay my rent,
then I could not have to
worry about trying to put food
on the table and actually
worry more about doing quality
comics, which would be great.
I haven't figured it out yet.
Although, to be
honest, I haven't tried
too hard to make my day job.
I don't know, I
feel like I almost
don't want it to be because if
it became the thing I got paid
to do and the thing that I
was making a living from,
I'm worried it
would become work.
And if it became work
and it was somehow
put a different kind
of pressure on it,
and I'm worried that that
would actually affect
the quality of the comic.
But I don't know.
I've never done
anything creative
in that way,
professionally before.
There's a ton.
I'm sure it'll be fine.
AUDIENCE: Do you know how
many readers you have?
MALACHI REMPEN: Readers?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MALACHI REMPEN: Yeah, sort of.
I've gotten to the
point, I first-- I've
crossed a milestone
I had for myself,
which was I wanted to meet
somebody and give them
my "Itchy Feet" business
card and then they would say,
oh, I've heard of you or
I have seen your work.
And that happened recently
and I was so excited.
Because it's like-- it makes
the world a smaller place.
So I don't actually
know the exact number.
I know I get a couple--
it varies depending
on whether the comic's any
good and whether people
respond to it or not.
Like, as far as
traffic goes, I get
between 10,000 and 20,000
unique visitors a month,
which for a lot of
comics is nothing.
That's pennies.
And for a lot of web
comics, that's a ton.
That's like incredible--
that's world fame.
I don't know.
I have no personal
metric against which
to say whether I have a
lot or a little viewers.
Fact is, I'm here.
I'm talking to you guys,
that's enough for me.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you do anything
to increase your readers,
like social media,
Facebook, [INAUDIBLE]?
MALACHI REMPEN: Do
I do anything to--
AUDIENCE: Make it popular.
MALACHI REMPEN: To publicize
it on social networks.
I'm just repeating
it for the video.
Do I do any self promotion
on social media and stuff.
Yeah, I do.
I pretty much just Reddit,
is the only one that I use.
The language learning community
there is really great.
And they support the comics.
They do it in a big way.
And on Facebook, it
kind of has a mind
of its own, the promotion thing.
So I publish it on Twitter.
That goes automatically
to Facebook.
It's all designed for me to
do as little work as possible.
But like, it's all automated
and then it goes out
and then I respond
to people, obviously,
when they talk to me.
I don't know.
I have a lot to learn
in this field, for sure.
And I think every day I'm
learning a little bit more
about it.
I think I need to up
the game a little bit.
For sure.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I found people
who said, within my work area,
I can get about six of the nine
tongue twisters from last week.
MALACHI REMPEN: OK.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering if you could
go through the ones in
Esperanto and Korean.
MALACHI REMPEN: Oh, now
you've put me on the spot.
I don't have it here.
AUDIENCE: Oh, here.
I've got it.
MALACHI REMPEN: Does
this have internet?
Could I just bring that up?
Like, if I could
bring up the site,
then I could just go to it.
And then is there like a-- nice.
Tongue twisters from
around the world.
So what do you mean you've got?
Like what do you mean got?
AUDIENCE: I could find
people who could read them
and sort of talk about
what they were about.
MALACHI REMPEN: What the
drawing behind it was.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
What the words were.
MALACHI REMPEN:
So the French one,
are the socks of
the arch Duchess
dry or very dry or is it
not dry. [SPEAKING FRENCH]
AUDIENCE: Very dry.
MALACHI REMPEN: Very dry.
So are they dry or very dry.
The second one is Italian.
I can actually say this
one. [SPEAKING ITALIAN]
Was that good?
IRIS: Si.
MALACHI REMPEN: On top of
the bench, the goat lives.
Under the bench, the goat dies.
The next one's in Russian.
I can't.
Can anyone do it here?
Russian.
OK go.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
MALACHI REMPEN: So Carl
steals Carla's coral
and Carla steals
Carl's clarinet,
which I think in English is a
perfectly good tongue twister.
The next one's Portuguese.
Anyone can do Portuguese here?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MALACHI REMPEN: In
Brazilian Portuguese.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
MALACHI REMPEN: OK.
And it could be that it's like
a Portugal Portuguese one.
And that just means,
from what I understand,
a rat gnaws on the cork of
the run of the King of Russia.
Right.
Japanese one, anyone?
Japanese?
AUDIENCE: Go for it.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
MALACHI REMPEN: And that
means, in the garden
of Mr. Neewa-- which I couldn't
fit into the drawing-- two
chickens suddenly
eat a crocodile.
That was really hard to
figure out how to draw that.
I'll say that.
I knew I had to.
I knew I had to draw that.
But like, two chickens
eating a crocodile.
Like how do two chickens
eat one crocodile?
The next one's Hebrew.
Anyone?
Anyone do Hebrew?
Oh, no.
I can't either.
And it sounds really funny, too.
It's like wo-do-wo-do-wo-do.
But it means, you were
supposed to clean the locker,
did you clean the locker?
I'm not going to
clean the locker?
You clean the locker.
That's what that one is.
Korean?
Anyone Hangul?
No.
AUDIENCE: I can
make [INAUDIBLE].
MALACHI REMPEN: Better
than mine, I'm sure.
AUDIENCE: It goes something
like this. [SPEAKING KOREAN].
MALACHI REMPEN: You
can even see it.
Like, well done.
Not bad, right, for
someone learning.
Fantastic.
So you can even see like I
love this like little circles.
Like, wan gan gan gan gan gan.
It even looks like-- a
tongue twister for your eyes.
And that means, Kang
is the president
of the soy sauce factory.
And Kong is the president
of the bean paste factory.
I mean, they're all
nonsense, right?
The next one's Turkish.
Can anyone do Turkish?
Turkish?
I'll do it.
I don't speak Turkish.
[SPEAKING TURKISH] And it
means, the branch bends
and the eagle takes off.
The eagle takes off
and the branch bends.
The last one, Esperanto.
Come on, someone, Esperanto.
Nobody here can do Esperanto?
This one I don't
know how to say it.
I guess [SPEAKING ESPERANTO]
Is my guess.
And it means-- oh,
what's this knife called?
Does anyone know this
particular kind of knife?
AUDIENCE: Machete.
MALACHI REMPEN: It's
like, that's the sword.
But there's like a knife,
like a kind of machete.
It's typical.
It's like a bow knife.
Not a now knife.
Bull knife.
Something like that.
So anyway, it's I hope
this large knife will
help you to scoop out the
brains of that Serbian deer.
Thanks, Esperanto.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you tell
us where we can buy
Liechtensteinian army knife?
MALACHI REMPEN: A
Liechtensteinian army knife.
Did you go to Liechtenstein?
AUDIENCE: Yeah. [INAUDIBLE].
MALACHI REMPEN: They didn't even
call them the Liechtensteinian
army knives?
Grandma didn't get
the Lichtenstein joke.
I have-- I guess I'm
not going to scroll
through the whole thing.
But I went to Liechtenstein
and it was basically exactly
like Switzerland,
except even smaller.
And they had the
same chocolates,
and the same cheeses,
and the same everything,
except they put
"Lichtenstein" on it.
But it's true.
They didn't actually do
that on the army knives.
You got me.
Are you happy?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Here's
a good question.
Back to the "Merry
Mariner" book, [INAUDIBLE].
MALACHI REMPEN: I'll show you.
How I get to the URL bar again?
So it's going to be
a series of books
that I'm going to do for print.
But for the moment,
they are short stories
that are set in that same
world that are-- they're
for free online right now.
I'm working on other versions.
Right now it's a PDF.
But I'm working on getting
them for iPad and Kindle
and so forth.
And there's going to be
six short stories with each
of the main characters.
It's about this family,
basically, of adventurers.
And each of these
short stories is
going to set from one
of their points of view.
And then there's going
to be a series of books
that come out after that.
But they're all
charmingly illustrated.
And it's like my childlike love
of old-- those books where you
open up and it's full of stuff.
It's full of diagrams.
And they've got
cutaways of things.
And they've got machines.
And they've got how things work.
And they've got recipes
and all kinds of stuff.
So in addition to being a
fully illustrated book series.
So right now they're
free online on the site.
Any other questions?
Thank you guys so much.
You were so, so great.